that's got to be tough because gre in
this in hollywood to be someone who's
religious now obviously we you've talked
about this ad nauseam and people know
about it but like you've gotten like
released or couldn't do roles or refuse
to do roles based on like you won't do a
kissing scene
right but someone's for some unless you
know the great yeah i won't do kissing
scenes i've never wanted to do it and
you know i got crucified about 10 years
ago where they thought i was this
religious zealot that i wouldn't do sex
scenes it was really because i love my
wife more than i love my craft and
people couldn't understand that i can't
they couldn't grasp that so i had to
become the best bad guy
because i had to provide for my five
kids and a beautiful wife and and so
you know
that's what i had to keep doing and then
finally a couple years ago when i
started to executive produce things i
did this movie called greater which is
this faith-based football film
a phenomenal movie and and
you know that started me on the trend of
doing these
good guys with this great past and
grappling with their faith and now this
this film that we just finished called
boon
uh is that he's a hitman who has to find
his placement with god and it's
you know it's great that i that and i
now get to create vehicles for me that i
get to write and and be in that i don't
have to just do
uh you know
movies that are out there that i have to
go fight for i can build my own movies
and and
craft them that way and so so for me to
also have that ability to to make movies
that talk about god and talk about how
we are flawed how we all make mistakes
and how it's it's how you you know get
up after you make a mistake not not not
wallowing in your mistake yeah a better
person and and i like making movies like
that tv shows like that and you know
that's if i never make a movie for
anyone else again for the rest of my
life
i'm okay with it
as long as i'm making movies that that
remain i'm doing and with a great
message i mean you know that you talk
about that and you do you think
when i it was scoundrels right that was
the big thing that scoundrels you
wouldn't do a sex scene or something and
then they released you and so you saying
after that it was it was a very
difficult time in your life for work i
mean were you or are you only getting
back talk about drink talk about
drinking men you know there was two
years of me not getting a job and losing
my
you know big house in hancock park and
cars and everything and begging from
this and
you know i was never a guy who would ask
to borrow money from anyone i'd rather
just figure out myself so i lost
basically everything
uh and then you know i've told the story
before that you know
you know and me being a great you know
going to church every day you're always
praying trying to figure out what's
going on
in one day in my house you know before
we had to sell it before i got
foreclosed on to start with
um
you know i remember saying to god why
have you forgotten about me what have i
done that i deserve this and as soon as
i came out of my mouth michael i fell to
the ground and started sobbing
uh and two minutes later i got a phone
call from graham yost who wrote band of
brothers in boom town goes hey you want
to be the villain on a couple episodes
of justify
yes i do
uh it was kind of the greatest thing
that ever happened to me in so many ways
because
i fell in love with acting again because
i had something to prove i had to prove
to everyone that you know that i am a
great actor and that you know a person
that you want to have on your set
you